bonjour à tous et merci d'avoir choisi
france 24 nous sommes donc en émission
spéciale bienvenue à vous si vous nous
rejoignez toutes nos équipes ici à paris
mais aussi en ukraine et partout dans le
monde sont mobilisés pour vous tenir
informé de la situation en ukraine
quelques heures après donc cette
intervention de vladimir poutine à la
télévision russe c'était ce matin à
l'aube le chef du kremlin qui a donc
autorisé une opération militaire
spéciale dans toute l'ukraine pas
seulement dans l'est des explosions ont
été entendues dans plusieurs villes kiev
mais aussi mario paul cramatte osc ville
dans l'est de l'ukraine qui sert de
quartier général à l'armée ukrainienne à
kharkiv également qui est la deuxième
ville du pays mais aussi à odessa sur la
mer noire on va prendre sans plus
attendre la direction de kiev où l'on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial clovis
casali bonjour clovis les sirènes ont
retenti 1 ce matin dans la capitale
ukrainienne que se passe-t-il sur place
a à l'heure actuelle
absolument des sirènes qui ont retenti à
ce matin à kiev on les entendait depuis
la place mais dan et invitant la
population à se mettre à l'abri on a
tous été réveillés aux alentours de 6
heures du matin par des explosions des
explosions au loin il semblerait que
l'aéroport de kiev est été touchées par
les forces russes on a parlé tout à
l'heure avec quelques ukrainien ya pas
beaucoup de monde dans les rues de kiev
aujourd'hui en tout cas où on se trouve
à meydan car dans d'autres quartiers il
semblerait que les supermarchés étaient
pris d'assaut en tout cas les ukrainiens
à qui nous avons parlé nous disent
qu'ils sont dans l'incompréhension mais
aussi la crainte qu'ils ont peur ils ont
été réveillés ce matin par ces
explosions tout de suite ils ont appelé
leur ami un peu partout dans le pays
pour savoir ce qu'il en était s'il avait
été touchée affectés par cette offensive
de grande envergure des forces de
vladimir poutine le président russe j'ai
aussi parlé avec des ukrainiens qui nous
disent qu'ils ne veulent pas la guerre
qu'ils n'ont jamais voulu la guerre
qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi ils
sont attaqués mais que s'il doit décider
soit s'ils doivent défendre leur maison
ils le feront ils ne vont pas partir ils
ne vont pas quitter les lieux néanmoins
à de nombreux ukrainiens ont pris la
route on dénombre deux très gros
embouteillages pas dans le centre ville
ici où je me trouve à meydan de kiev
mais à la sortie de la ville des
ukrainiens qui essayent de quitter la
zone qui cherchent à quitter le pays
j'ai parlé notamment avec une
ukrainienne qui très tôt ce matin aux
alentours de 7 heures avaient pris la
route avec sa famille elle a dû faire
chemin inverse car elle ne pouvait pas
sortir c'était pas clair si les bush ont
été causés par des forces de l'ordre qui
empêchaient les gens de partir ou si
c'était simplement la circulation qui
était trop dense en tout cas elle était
elle est allée ensuite à une station
essence des stations essence qui sont
pris d'assaut pris d'assaut tout
simplement parce que les gens ont peur
les gens veulent se ravitailler que ce
soit en vivres ou en naissant en eau en
essence à car ils sont dans
l'incompréhension dans l'inquiétude ils
ne savent pas vraiment ce qui va se
passer ce qui est ce qui va se passer
dont les prochaines heures en tout cas
je peux vous dire qu'ici à meydan à kiev
depuis environ deux heures on n'entend
plus d'explosions contrairement à ce
matin où elles étaient nombreuses merci
beaucoup clovis rester avec nous on va
écouter tout de suite le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky qui tente
de rassurer les ukrainiens qui les
appellent à rester calme il s'est
entretenu avec plusieurs dirigeants le
président français notamment le
président américain on les coûts tout de
suite
bravo
de mont-royal instant la cité les
touristes avaient remarqué des voitures
et
vitrines seront ni de vase et voici à
quoi je n'ose
cependant je reste et
voilà le président ukrainien qui a
décrété la loi martiale donc et qui
appelle les ukrainiens à rester chez eux
clovis
oui à rester chez eux hier le parlement
ratifié voter cet état d'urgence qui
empêche les réservistes de quitter le
pays qui mobilise toute la nation et
toute la nation ukrainienne est
mobilisée notamment pour aider les
troupes au front
bandé
argent qu il semblerait que au corps et
au stif
les troupes c'est certain je vais vous
efforts de l'ukraine qui s'est mobilisé
on vous entendre vous entends vous a
récupéré continue et clovis
est donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya un effort de guerre ici en
ukraine et on a appris à tout à l'heure
que le président a zelensky via le
commandant en chef des armées des forces
armées ukrainiennes avaient déclaré
qu'il fallait infliger le maximum de
pertes à l'ennemi russe qui a donc en
veille selon eux est vraisemblablement
selon tous les allées les rapports les
témoignages envoyés à différentes zones
du pays une invasion à russes les
ukrainiens se mobilise l'état d'urgence
vous l'avez dit hier pour mobiliser les
réservistes et aussi danser dans tout
dans ces cas de figure et bien il y à de
nombreuses voix pour empêcher aussi le
les
rassemblements les les lois sur les
partis et c'est avec la loi martiale qui
a été a décidé aujourd'hui de toute
urgence il faut savoir aussi que l'état
d'urgence qui est une autre un autre une
autre loi bien sûr et bien et est en
place depuis 2014 dans la province de
louhansk et donetsk car le cren depuis
des mois depuis des années satan se
prépare à une invasion russe en tout cas
la craignait